karamba diaby first day in Parliament
went off without a hitch like all newly
elected members of the Bundestag he
received a welcome package with a pass
for the subway an identity card and a
list of important telephone numbers the
Social Democrat took the day in his
stride in some business of Quebec Gulf
yeah of course I'm excited about my
first parliamentary session but I think
that's just natural there was also
plenty of media attention making a good
impression in front of the camera is
part of the job but Diaby says he's
ready to start working on the issues
it's filling up I've been politically
active for a long time now then one day
I got the opportunity to start working
on bigger political issues it's the
bundestag is the best venue for solving
those problems is the best it's the
great iam tough you karamba diaby
constituency is in the eastern german
city of Halla for months he crisscrossed
the city trying to convince voters of
his party's program his campaign promise
more educational opportunities and a
national minimum wage SPD leaders came
to holler to support dr b's campaign
chancellor candidate peer Steinbrueck
accompanied the rising politician on one
of his meet and greets dr be attracted
enormous international attention in his
bid to get elected to Germany's
Parliament most Germans say they want a
grand coalition in government with the
SPD as a junior partner whatever happens
voters in Halle are relying on Diaby and
his party to keep their campaign
promises